let's start with the sideburns this is
an important part right here because you
want it to blend it to the hair that's
already there you don't want to go too
short so get into it and just use a nice
upward stroking motion all right so I'm
gonna knock this down with the liner
when ticking down the facial hair around
the mustache area this is the one area
where you kind of want to go with the
grain you don't necessarily need to go
against the grain because you don't want
to cause too much irritation in this
area also a great tool to use to remove
the hair is the wall peanut which is a
great liner to use for home use know
you're all cleaned up and you got your
stubble what you want to do is establish
your cybers and make sure they're in the
right area and just use like the
Frankenstein technique which is where
you take one finger put it on the
sideburn right below it and the other
and you can see that they're lining up
so that's how you know your sideburns
are correct all right let's do the safe
first thing we do is add water now that
we have our water and our oil on the
face then I'm going to put a little bit
of some shaving cream on there so right
now we'll use a straight razor on John
at home you can use any type of razor
you like whether it be a cartridge razor
or a safety razor I always recommend to
go with the grain first just to minimize
any type of irritation
I feel one of the most important things
that sometimes guys don't use is an
aftershave a moisturizer so an a great
aftershave you don't necessarily have to
buy an aftershave you can just use a
nice alcohol free moisturizer I really
like to use the Malon against vitamin E
moisturizer it's light it absorbs into
the skin really nice
so here's John clean-shaven and beard
totally gone